WESLEY CHUN: Hey, everybody.
This is Wesley Chun, an
engineer here at Google.
Today, I'm going to introduce
you to one of our best
kept secrets--
Google Apps Script.
You're kidding, right?
Another Google secret?
All right, so it's not our best
kept secret nor is it really
a secret at all.
But if you haven't
heard of it yet,
you'll be wondering why you
haven't by the time we're done.
So, first things first.
What is Google Apps Script?
Well, it's a tool
based on JavaScript,
but it's a little less like
using APIs and more like using
services or built-in
access to APIs.
And finally, there's less OAuth2
authorization code for you
to write.
All right, to help with
this understanding,
let's start with what
Apps Script is not.
All right, the good news here is
that there's really nothing new
to learn.
It's just JavaScript.
Even a Python guy like
me knows some JavaScript.
But it's not your
daddy's JavaScript.
Aside from one
exception which is out
of the scope of this
episode, Apps Script code
is not client-side and does
not run in the browser,
meaning there's no DOM
manipulation like you
see behind me.
The other thing you
do in the browser
is edit your Apps Script code.
Now, if you're
familiar with Node.js,
it's like Node being
server-side and all, only you're
not running asynchronous
event-driven code executing
on Node servers.
Instead, your Apps
Script code runs
on the same servers in
the same data centers that
run Google services, like
Search, YouTube, and Gmail,
giving you access
to resources that
don't come with Node servers.
All right, based
on its name, you
can probably guess that Apps
Script will give you access
to Google Apps
data and services,
but it doesn't stop there.
You can access other
Google services
beyond Apps, such as
Google Maps, YouTube,
Google Analytics, BigQuery,
and Google Translate.
Here's a more complete
list, and we're
continuing to look at what to
add next that benefits users.
You may be asking what you
can use Apps Script for
and there are many use cases,
but a good rule of thumb
is to think a programmatic way
to access data in Google Apps,
possibly using other
Google services.
Oh, by the way, if you
look down at the bottom,
those in the Other
Services section
allow your app to communicate
with outside world
to go beyond Google services.
Here are some
sample applications.
Apps like teacher tools that use
data in Google Docs and Sheets.
Mail merge apps are popular too.
You know, form
letters in Google Docs
merging with email
addresses in Google Sheets
and sent by Gmail.
Now, school districts
and enterprises
using Google Apps
for their domain
have many use cases, such
as workflow and resource
management, such as
this calendaring app.
Now, there are three
types of Apps Script apps.
Standalone scripts that run by
themselves, as you can guess,
add-ons, and document-bound
scripts, which
are tied to a specific document,
such as Docs or Sheets.
Finally, Apps Script can do
simple websites as well as
gadgets bound to Google sites.
OK, that's enough talk.
Let's do some coding.
Your Hello World will
be a Sheets-bound script
that writes Hello World to the
first cell in a Google Sheet,
all right?
Let's follow me to the computer
right now so we can do that.
All righty.
You guys all set to do
your first Apps Script App?
Me too.
I'm happy to have
you guys join me.
So why don't you go
to your Google Drive
and create a brand
new spreadsheet.
And once you're done,
come join me back here
and we'll pick up from here.
All right.
Let's go and write
some Apps Script code.
So, the way you do that is you
go to your spreadsheet's Tools
menu item.
You scroll down and
select Script Editor.
And what that will do is it
will bring up a little dialog
box that has a bunch
of boilerplate code
already written for you.
But since we're only going
to do a simple one-liner,
we're just going to
pick Blank Project.
If you're going to do something
a little bit more complicated,
you may consider choosing
one of these other skeleton
bits of code that have
prebuilt functionality for you.
But for now, let's
just do Blank Project.
And what this will do is it will
pop you into the Apps Script
JavaScript editor that's
in your web browser.
And it's already started
the first function for you.
So all we're going to do
is go to our spreadsheet
and stick Hello
World as a string
into the first cell in
our spreadsheet, which
is located at A1.
So, column A, row number 1.
So the way you do that is you
connect to the spreadsheet app
by typing SpreadsheetApp.
And once you press dot,
you have a selector
where you can choose
from specific methods
that you can call.
So what we're going to
do is we're going to call
the getActiveSheet() method
to get the current sheet that
we're on.
And from here we're going to
get the first cell, or the cell
in the upper left-hand corner,
and use getRange for that.
And we're going
to use a1Notation,
and we're going to
specify the string that
says we want cell A1.
And there we go.
And then once we
have the cell, let's
write the Hello
World string to it.
And the method you use
for that is setValue.
So there we go there.
And now we can enter Hello
World and Save and Run.
Here's the Run button here.
It's a little triangle.
Once you click it, it asks
you to save it and name it.
So let's do that here.
We'll call it Hello World.
And once it's saved,
we can run it again.
Now, notice that
none of this code
had any OAuth in it, right?
So, one of the advantages you
get from using Apps Script
is that you don't have to build
all this in yourself like you
would if you were using a
traditional REST-based API.
Apps Script handles
all this for you.
And you can see that here where
it says, hey, you know what?
This script needs
authorization before it
can get access to your data.
So once you click
on this, you'll
get your very familiar
OAuth2 dialogue
that basically says you as a
user need to give permission
to access your Google Sheet.
See, it says here "View and
Manage Your Spreadsheets
in Google Drive."
Obviously, we want that
to happen because we're
trying to automate
things for ourselves.
So we click Accept.
And once that's
done, it's actually
going to run your script, and
you can see the little dialog
box up here that
says it's running.
And once it's done,
it disappears.
Hopefully, when you
go to your spreadsheet
you'll see that we have
Hello World in cell A1,
just as we had planned.
All right.
Now, if for some reason your
browser window is not that wide
or you want to make your
code a little easier to read,
you can do the
JavaScript shortcut
way of putting each method
call on a separate line.
It's perfectly fine.
I can do that here.
Let's just change our
script a little bit
because I want to run it again
to show that it did work.
All right.
So let's click on Run again.
And once that's done, we'll
go back to the spreadsheet
and see, hey, we've
got Hello World 2.
So that's it.
You've just done your
first Hello World program
using Google Apps Script.
Congratulations.
All right.
Now that you've got Hello
World under your belt,
I'm sure you're anxious
to script some more.
Here you'll find a link to
the Apps Script documentation,
which includes tutorials as
well as Quick Start projects
to get you going.
Also, stay tuned for more Apps
Script episodes coming soon.
If you need help,
go to Stack Overflow
and search for Google
Apps Script with hyphens
in between each word.
All right.
Now, can you believe you haven't
heard of Google Apps Script
before?
Yeah, neither can I, but now the
secret's really out of the bag,
isn't it?
All right.
This is Wesley Chun from
Google, and I look forward
to seeing some awesome
Apps Scripts from you.
Thanks for tuning in to this
episode of the Launchpad
Online.